[Music]
I don't know about you but um I haven't
quite figured out exactly what
technology means in my life I've spent
the past year thinking about what it
really should be about should I be Pro
technology should I embrace it full arms
should I be worried like you I'm very
tempted by the latest thing but at the
other hand a couple years ago I gave up
all that my possessions sold all my
technology except for a bicycle and
wrote across 3,000 miles on the u.s.
back roads under the power of my one
body fueled mostly by Twinkies and junk
food and I've since then tried to keep
technology at arm's length many ways so
it doesn't master my life at the same
time I've run a website on cool tools
where I issue a daily obsession of the
latest things in technology so I'm still
perplexed about what the true meaning of
technology is as it relates to humanity
as it relates to nature as it relates to
the spiritual and I'm not even sure we
know what technology is and one
definition of technology is that which
is first recorded this is the first
example of the modern use of technology
that I can find it was a suggested
syllabus for dealing with the applied
arts in science in Cambridge University
in 1829 before that obviously technology
didn't exist but obviously it did I
liked one of the definitions that Alan
Kay has for technology
he says technology is anything that was
invented after you were born
so it's sums up a lot of what we're
talking about Danny Hillis actually has
an update on that he says technology is
anything that doesn't quite work yet
which also I think gets into a little
bit of our current idea but I was
interested in another definition of
Technology something again that went
back to something more fundamental
something that was deeper and as I
struggled to understand that I came up
with a way of framing the question that
seemed to work for me and my
investigations and I'm this morning
going to talk about this for the first
time so this is a very rough attempt to
to think out loud and the question that
he came up with was this question what
does technology want and by that I don't
mean does it want chocolate or vanilla
by what at once I mean what are its
inherent trends and biases what are its
tendencies over time one way to think
about this is thinking about biological
organisms which we've heard a lot about
and in the trick that Richard Dawkins
does which is to say to look at them as
simply as genes as vehicles for genes so
he's saying what do genes want The
Selfish Gene and I'm applying a similar
trick to say what week we looked at the
universe in our culture through the eyes
of Technology
what does technology want obviously this
is an incomplete question just as
looking at an orgasm as only a gene is
an incomplete way of looking at it but
still very very productive so I'm
attempting to say if we take
technologies view of the world what does
it want and I think once we ask that
question we have to go back actually to
life because obviously if we keep
extending the origins of technology far
back I think we come back to life at
some point so that's where I want to
begin my little exploration is in life
and like you heard from the previous
speakers we don't really know what life
there is on earth right now we have
really no idea we're Craig Venters
tremendous and brilliant attempt to to
DNA sequence things in the ocean is
great Brian Farrell's work is all part
of this
to try and actually discover all the
species on earth and one of the things
we should do is just make a grid of the
globe and randomly go and inspect all
that all the places that the grid
intersects just to see what some life
and if we did that with our little
Martian probe which we have not done on
earth we would begin to see some
incredible species this is not an
another plant these these are things
that are hidden away on our planet this
is an ant that stores its colleagues
honey in its abdomen each one of these
organisms that we've described have you
seen from Jamie and others these
magnificent things what they're doing
each one of them is they're hacking the
rules of life I can't think of a single
general principle of biology that is not
have an exception somewhere by some
organism every single thing we can think
of and if you heard Olivia's talk about
the sexual habits you will realize that
there isn't anything we can say that's
true for all life because every single
one of them is hacking something about
it this is a solar-powered sea slug it's
a neuter product that has incorporated
in chloroplasts inside it to drive its
energy this is another version of that
this is a sea dragon and the one on the
bottom is a blue one is the juvenile
that has not yet swallowed the acid is
not yet taken in the brown green algae
pond scum into its body to give it
energy these are hacks and if we looked
at the general shape of the approaches
to hacking life there are current
consensus six kingdoms six different
broad approaches the plants the animals
the fungi the protists the little things
the bacteria and the Archaea bacteria
the are keys
those are the general approaches to life
that's one way to look at life on Earth
today but a more interesting way the
current way to take the long view is to
look at it in an evolutionary
perspective and here we have a view of
evolution where rather than having
evolution go over the linear time we
have a coming out from the center so in
the center is the most primitive and
is a genealogical chart of all life on
earth this is all the same six kingdoms
you see four thousand representative
species you can see where we are but
what I like about this is it shows that
every living organism on Earth today is
equally evolved those those fungi and
bacteria are as highly evolved as humans
they've been around this is long gone
through just the same kind of trial and
error to get here but we see that what
each one of these is actually hacking
and has a different way of finding out
how to do life and if we take the long
term trends of life if we begin to say
what are the what does evolution want
there are several things that we see one
things about evolution is that nowhere
on earth on earth have we ever been
where we don't find life we find life at
the bottom of every long term a long
distance drilling core of into the
center of rock and we bring it up and
there's bacteria in the pores of that
rock and wherever life is and never
retreats it's ubiquitous and it's
becoming wants to be more more and more
of the inert matter of the of the globe
is being touched and animated by life
the second thing is as we see diversity
we also see specialization we see the
movement from a general purpose cell to
the more specific and specialized and we
see a drift towards complexity that's
very intuitive and actually we have
current data that does show that there
is actual drift towards complexity over
time and the last thing I bring back
this new tube rock is one of the things
we see about life is that it moves from
the inert to increasing sociability and
by that it means that there is more and
more of life whose entire environment is
other life like those chloroplast cells
they're completely surrounded by other
life and they never touch the inert
matter there is more and more
coevolution and so the general long-term
trends of evolution are roughly these
five ubiquity diversity specialization
complexity and socialization now I took
that and said okay what are the
long-term trends in technology and
again my question is what does
technology want and so remarkably I
discovered that there's also a drift or
specialization
that we see there's a general hammer and
hammers become more and more specific
over time
there's obviously diversity huge numbers
of things this is all the contents of a
Japanese home I actually had my daughter
gave her a tally counter and I gave her
an assignment last summer to go around
and count the number of species of
technology in our household and came up
with 6,000 different species of products
I did some research to found out that
the King of England Henry the Eighth had
only about 7,000 items in his household
and he was the king of England and that
was the entire wealth of England at the
time so we're seeing huge numbers of
diversity in the kinds of things this is
a scene from Star Wars where the GPO
comes out and he sees machines making
machines how depraved well this is
actually what we're headed towards world
machines and the technology is only
being surrounded by other technologies
most machines will only ever be in
contact with other technology and not
non technology or even life and thirdly
the idea that machines are becoming a
biological and complex is at this point
a cliche I'm happy to say I was partly
responsible for that cliche that
machines are becoming biological but
that's pretty evident so the major
trends in technology evolution actually
are the same as in biological evolution
the same drives that we see torez
ubiquity tourist diversity tourist
socialization towards complexity that is
maybe not big surprise because if we map
out say the evolution of of armor you
can actually follow sort of an
evolutionary type cladistic tree I
suggest that in fact technology is the
seventh kingdom of life that its
operations at how it works is so similar
that we can think of it as the seventh
kingdom and so it would be sort of
approximately up there coming out of the
animal kingdom and if we were to do that
we would find out we could actually
approach technology in this way this is
not
Eldridge he was the co developer with
Stephen Jay Gould of the theory of
punctuated equilibrium but as a sideline
he happens to collect cornets he has won
the world's most largest collections
about 500 of them and he's decided to
treat them as if they were tribal lights
or snails and to do a morphological
analysis and tried to derive their
genealogical history over time this is
his chart which is not quite published
yet but the most interesting aspect
about this is that if you look at those
red lines at the bottom those indicate
basically a parentage of of a type of
cornet that was no longer made that does
not happen in biology once something is
thinking you can't have it as your
parent but that does happen in
technology and it turns out that that's
so distinctive that you can actually
look at this tree and you can you can
actually use it to decide to determine
that this is a technological system
versus a biological system in fact this
idea that that of resurrecting old ideas
is so important that I began to think
about what happens with old technology
and it turns out that in fact
technologies don't die so I suggested
this to a historian of science and he
said what what about you know come on
what about steam cars you know they're
not around anymore well actually they
are in fact they're so around that you
can buy new parts for a Stanly steam on
mobile and this is a website of a guy
who's selling brand-new parts for the
stanley automobile and the thing that
really I like to serve this one click
add to your cart button for buying steam
power steam valves I mean it was just it
was really there and so I began to think
about well what I mean maybe that's just
a random sample maybe I should do this
little more conservative way so I took
the great big 19 I'm excuse me 1895
Montgomery Ward's catalog and I randomly
went through it and it took a page not
quite a random page it took a page was
actually more difficult than others
because lots of the pages were filled
with things that were still being made
but I took this page and I said how many
of these things are still being made and
antiques I want to know how many of
these things are still in production and
the answer is all of them all of them
are still being produced so you've got
corn shellers whoo I mean I don't know
who needs the corn shall it be a corn
sellers you've got plows you've got fan
mills all these things and these are not
again it takes these are you can order
these you can go to the web and you can
buy them now brand-new made so so in a
certain sense technologies don't die in
fact you can you can buy for 50 bucks a
stone-age knife made exactly the same
way that they were made 10,000 years ago
at shirt bone handle 50 bucks in fact
what's important is that this
information actually never died out it's
not just that it was resurrected it's
continued all along and Papua New Guinea
they were making stone axes until two
decades ago just as a course of
practical matters even when we try to
get rid of a technology it's actually
very hard so we've all heard about the
Amish giving up cars we've heard about
the Japanese giving up guns we've heard
about this and that but I actually went
back and took what I could find
the examples in history would there have
been prohibitions against technology and
then I tried to find out when they work
when they came back in because they
always came back in and it turns out
that the time the duration of when they
were outlawed and prohibited is
decreasing over time and that basically
you can delay technology but you can't
kill it so this makes sense because a
certain sense what culture is is culture
is the accumulation of ideas that's what
it's for is so the ideas don't die out
and when we take that we take this idea
of what culture is doing and added to
what the long-term trajectory again in
in in in life's evolution we find that
each case each of the major transitions
in life what they're really about is
accelerating and changing the way in
which evolution happens they're actually
changing the way in which ideas are
generated so all these steps in
evolution are increasing basically the
evolution of evolvability so what's
happening over time in life is that the
ways in which you generate these new
ideas these new hacks are increasing and
the the the real tricks are ways in
which you kind of explore the way of
exploring and that what we see in the
singularity the prophesized by Kurzweil
II and others is idea that technology is
accelerating evolution it's accelerating
the way in which we search for ideas so
what if you have life hacking life means
hacking the game of survival then
evolution is a way to extend the game by
changing the rules of the game and what
technology is really about is better
ways to evolve that is what we call an
infinite game that's the definition of
infinite game a finite game is played to
win an infinite game is played to keep
playing and I believe that technology is
actually a cosmic force the origins of
technology was not in 1829 but was
actually at the beginning of the Big
Bang and at that moment the entire huge
billions of stars in universe were
compressed the entire universe was
compressed into a little quantum dot and
it was so tight in there there was no
room for any difference at all that's
the definition there was no temperature
there was no difference whatsoever and
at the Big Bang when it expanded was the
potential for difference so as it
expands and as things expand what we
have is we have the potential for
differences diversity options choices
opportunities possibilities and freedoms
those are all basically the same thing
and those are the things that technology
bring us that's what technology is
bringing us choices possibilities
freedoms that's what it's about is this
expansion of room to make differences
and so a hammer when we grab a hammer
that's what we're grabbing and that's
why we continue to grab technology
because we want those things those
things are good differences freedom
choices possibilities and each time we
make a new opportunity place were
allowing a platform to make new ones and
I think it's really important because if
you can imagine Mozart before the
technology of the piano was invented
what a loss to society that would be
imagine van Gogh being born before the
technologies of cheap oil paints imagine
Hedgehog before the technologies of film
somewhere today there are millions of
young children being born whose
technology of self-expression has not
yet been invented we have a moral
obligation to invent technology so that
every person on the globe has the
potential to realize their true
difference we want a trillion zillion
species of one individuals that's what
technology really wants I'm going to
skip through some of the objections
because I don't have answers to why
there's deforestation I don't have an
answer to the fact that there are seemed
to be bad technologies I don't have an
answer to how this impacts on our
dignity other than to suggest that maybe
the seventh kingdom because it's so
close to what life is about
maybe we can bring it back and have it
monitor help us monitor life maybe in
some ways the fact that that what we're
trying to do with technology is find a
good home for it it's a terrible thing
to spray DDT on on cotton fields but
it's a really good thing to use to
eliminate millions of cases of death due
to malaria in a small village our
humanity is actually defined by
technology all the things that we think
that we really like about humanity is
being driven by technology this is the
infinite game that's what we're talking
about you see technology is a way to
evolve the evolution it's a way to
explore possibilities and opportunities
and create more and it's actually a way
of playing the game of playing all the
games that's what technology wants and
so when I think about what technology
wants I think that it has to do with the
fact that every person here and I really
believe this every person here has an
assignment and your assignment is to
spend your life discovering what your
assignment is that recursive nature is
the infinite game and if you play that
well you'll have other people's involved
so even that game extends and continues
even when you're gone that is the
infinite game and what technology is is
the medium in which we play that
infinite game and so I think we should
embrace technology because it is an
essential part
of our journey to finding out who we are
thank you
[Applause]
what if great ideas weren't cherished
what if they carried no importance
[Music]
or held no value there is a place where
artistic vision is protected where
inspired design ideas live on to become
ultimate driving machines
[Music]
you